bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est
sens public votre rendez-vous de débat
et le reportage sur Public Sénat 90
minutes pour donner nu sens à
l'actualité aux crises et aux conflits
que nous traversons et c'est une
émission spéciale que nous vous
proposons ce soir après les attaques
terroristes du Hamas contre Israël une
offensive d'une ampleur sans précédent
sur le sol de l'État hébreu visant des
militaires et des
civils ce à quoi nous assistons ce sont
des crimes de guerre
des crimes de guerre flagrants et
barbares des civils massacrés des otages
maltraités des bébés arrachés à leur
mère il n'y a pas de mot pour décrire
une telle
sauvagerie ce soir le bilan est encore
provisoire plus de 700 morts 2500
blessés côté israélien sans oublier les
otages entre 100 et 150 personnes
détenues par le Hamas ce qui rend la
repost particulièrement compliquée à
mettre en œuvre une roste militaire qui
a déjà commencé faisant plus de 560
morts côté palestinien et qui passe
notamment par un siège complet de la
bande de Gaza comment le Hamas a-t-il pu
préparer une telle opération sans
réaction des services secrets israéliens
quel a été le rôle de l'Iran et du Qatar
les habituels soutiens de l'organisation
terroriste palestinienne et puis quels
sont quelles seront les conséquences
diplomatique de cette attaque sans
précendent on répondra entre autres à
toutes ces questions avec nos invité
expert mais d'abord le récit de cette
journée de combat avec Quentin
Calmet l'armée israélienne est ici en
cours de déploiement autour de la bande
de Gaza c'est la dernière étape avant le
siège complet de l'enclave annoncé par
le ministère israélien de la
Défense déjà de nombreuses frappes ont
touché Gaza en réplique à l'attaque
surprise menée depuis samedi par le
Hamas aujourd'hui les combats ont
d'ailleurs continué dans plusieurs
localités en Israël l'armée assure avoir
repris le contrôle de ces villages au
sud mais les terroristes pourrai encore
être nombreux dans ces
zones nous avons totalement évacué la
population de 15 des 24 collectivités
limitrophes de la bande de Gaza nous
sommes sur le point d'achever
l'évacuation dans les 24 prochaines
heures le Hamas a également eu le temps
de faire plus d'une centaines d'otages
transporté de force depuis samedi à Gaza
cette femme cherche sa mère disparue
depuis 48
he j'ai reçu une vidéo indiquant qu'elle
avait été kidnappée et que des membres
du Hamas l'avait enlevé dans sa maison
avec son mari et deux voisins et qu'il
les avait emmené en dehors du kibut nous
pensons qu'ils sont à Gaza et je suis
venu ici pour le
signaler le sort de ces otages est dans
l'esprit de tous en Israël le Hamas
assure que quatre israéliens sont morts
lors des frappes qui ont touché Gaza la
situation dans l'enclave se tend d'heure
en heure dans cet hôpital on craint
d'être rapidement privé d'électricité et
de matériel
médical en cas de pénurie de matériel
médical de fou d'oxygène ou de pann
d'électricité le nombre de victimes
augmentera le grand nombre de blessés
auquel nous sommes confrontés nécessite
une intervention urgente et le matériel
doit être fourni au ministère de la
Santé le plus rapidement
possible le bilan est lourd 3 jours
après le début de ce nouvel épisode de
violence il serait de plus de 1200
personnes tuées au total et des milliers
blessés israël compte plus de 700 morts
dont deux Français 560 côté palestinien
les otages compteraient également de
nombreux
binationaux comprendre comment une telle
attaque terroriste a été possible
comment comprendre comment israël
prépare et active s ripose voilà le les
principales questions de ce premier
débat première partie de cette émission
spéciale avec Jérôme clège bonsoir
bienvenueons vous êtes enseignant en
prospective et stratégie à Scien pour
Paris auteur de ce livre la prospective
stratégique aux éditions her Martine
goslan bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
grand reporteur à Marianne et je cite
votre livre Israël 70 ans 7p clés pour
comprendre aux éditions de l'archipel
Sami Cohen bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi directeur de recherche et mérit à
Science Po votre livre de salle à
l'épreuve du terrorisme aux éditions du
Seuil on est également en duplexe avec
Raphaël jérusalemi qui est ancien
officier du renseignement militaire
israélien bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation évidemment Mathieu
croissant politique est à mes côtés euh
Jérôme clash est-ce que vous faites
l'analogie avec le le 11 septembre pour
qualifier l'attaque terroriste du ramas
contre Israël dans le sens il y aura un
avant et un après ça change presque la
grille de lecture oui si si c'est dans
le sens où cet événement constitue
quelque chose non seulement d'inédit
mais une véritable fracture une
véritable véritable bouleversement oui
euh par la portée symbolique évidemment
on le sait avec que 50 ans plus tard 50
ans après la guerre du Kip pour
naturellement ça a un sens en revanche
euh est-ce que on peut faire un rapport
avec le 11 septembre dans les modalités
euh pas vraiment en fait là on assiste à
quoi en fait cette fois-ci on assiste à
un attentat euh dans un premier temps
c'est d'abord la dimension aérienne
c'est d'abord euh un volume inédit de
roquettes 5000 roquettes qui sont tirées
et qui de ce point de vue-là en fait
font l'objet d'une réponse aussi bonne
que possible de la part du Dôme de fer
qui a quand même évité jusqu'à 90 95 %
des roquettes et évidemment ça c'est le
système de défense antirien c'est le
système de défense anti-aérien mais en
revanche sur la dimension aérroterrestre
sur la CAP la la la dimension finalement
un petit peu asymétrique de de cette de
ce conflit euh elle est très éloignée de
ce que nous avons pu connaître il y a 50
ans puisque là c'était l'Égypte contre
contre Israël dans une une dimension
très conventionnelle voilà ici c'est
véritablement une approche asymétrique
où les armes sont des armes par
destination d'une certaine manière des
parapandes des paramoteur se transforme
en arme d'infiltration et c'est là où
éventuellement on peut faire un rapport
avec la question que vous posiez le 11
septembre 2001 où là aussi on avait des
armes par destination puisque c'est un
avion de ligne civile qui s'est
transformé finalement en missile c'est
là où on peut faire le rapprochement
mais c'est quand même assez différent en
fait dans les modalités euh
effectivement mais mais c'est peut-être
plus sur les conséquences et on y
reviendra évidemment dans ce débat et
aussi dans notre second débat Martine
goseland selon une nos confrères de
l'agence AP Associated Press qui cite
une source anonyme égyptienne l'Égypte
aurait prévenu l'État hébreux de
l'hypothèse une attaque de de grande
ampleur c'est vraiment l'une des
question principale qu'on se pose depuis
48h comment comment les services
secretsiens ont pu ne pas anticiper ne
pas réagir alors euh sur la sur la
source égyptienne bon on peut la mettre
en pointiller mais il y a une il y a des
choses qui commence à émerger depuis
donc depuis depuis Israël du sein
d'Israël c'est-à-dire que à plusieurs
reprises euh dans un pays en grave crise
politique alors que des manifestations
euh depuis depuis 8 mois hbran l'État
hébreu les les services de renseignement
et les états-majors étaient évidemment
euh en conflit avec le gouvernement avec
benjamine Netanyahou et sa coalition
composée de d'extrémistes et à plusieurs
reprises ils ont ils ont voulu ils ont
tenté euh de prévenir euh netaniaou
qu'il y avait des risques sur la
sécurité de l'État hébreux quel genre de
risque euh c'est en tout cas ils savaiit
que euh ils avaient trouvé que euh des
dépouiller complètement la frontière la
frontière Sud et la barrière de sécurité
à Erz de ces bataillons était totalement
fou il y a eu un conflit là-dessus un
conflit inter les tr/4 des bataillons é
vers la Jordanie mais pas seulement vers
la S Jordanie oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs
il y avait une logique dans le fait de
transférer une partie des bataillons
vers la sjordanie parce que la sjordanie
est le théâtre depuis plusieurs mois d'
d'une réelle Intifada mais ce qui ce
qu'il aurait fallu c'est en laisser
quelquesuns ils n' ils n'ont pas laissé
de bataillon et le pire ce que me ce que
me disent les Israéliens que j'ai au
téléphone depuis 48h c'est que en plus
il y avait tout un bataillon entier la
veille de de de l'attaque du ramas qui
était dévolue à la protection d'une
d'une d'une grande prière euh
organisé pour la fin de de souscôte par
des ultr orthodoxes et et quand même des
des gens assez radicaux donc euh c'est
c'est c'est quelque chose euh c'est
quelque chose qui commence à émerger
donc il y a se désorgan on va continuer
de d'analyser ça avec Raphaël jérusalemi
qui est avec nous en duplexe je rappelle
ancien officier du renseignement
militaire israélien comment vous vous
analysez ce qui s'est passé est-ce que
vous faites effectivement un lien avec
le la contestation qui s'exprime dans la
rue depuis des mois contre la réforme de
la justice voulu par par Benjamin
netaniaou et son gouvernement des des
tensions internes à l'armée au service
secret israélien est-ce que c'est
possible ça d'après
vous oui tout à fait d'ailleurs les
ennemis d'Israël l'ont dit haut eff fort
dès le début ils ont perçu dans la
controverse politique et le chaos social
qui agitait Israël un affaiblissement de
la nation hébreu ils l'ont dit eux-mêmes
et ils ont considéré que cet
affaiblissement pouvait créer
effectivement l'occasion à ne pas rater
euh de s'en prendre à l'État hébreu
affaibli trop trop occupé par ailleurs
euh à C ces polémiques internes alors
c'est vrai euh d'un autre côté il y a
quand même deux raisons à cet échec car
c'est un échec évidemment des services
de renseignement elles sont différentes
de nature la première est plus à long
terme et plus conceptuelle il y a eu une
mésappréhension pendant de très longues
années euh de ce qu'il fallait faire du
ramas euh et quand je dis de très
longues années ce sont des gouvernements
successifs mais en majorité des
gouvernements qui étaient sous euh la
houlette de Benjamin nataniaou qui lui a
toujours considéré que le ramas était en
fin de compte une bonne chose parce que
le ramas divisait l'Autorité
palestinienne affaiblissait l'OLP
aramala le le régime d'abouazen et il
trouvit ça
malin de diviser les Palestiniens et
puis il a toujours eu cette parole de
dire mieux vaut un ennemi qu'on connaît
que je ne sais quoi après ou d'avoir
pire je ne sais pas ce qui peut d' avoir
pire on vient de de voir euh et donc il
il y a eu pendant des années euh ce
laxisme politique qui a permis
d'ailleurs il y a eu beaucoup de round
entre Gaza et Israël violent mais après
chaque round euh il y a eu une sorte de
cesser le feu on a jamais fini le boulot
et après chaque round au bout de
quelques semaines seulement le Hamas le
jjihad islamique se sont regroupés
restructurer re re refinancé et repris
en plus le contrôle évidemment de la
bande de
et donc ça c'est à long terme alors je
je vais vous redonner la parole sur le
le l'autre effet mais je voudrais qu'on
qu'on réagisse parce que c'est
effectivement très intéressant sur
peut-être un ce que je comprends quand
on quand notreur r parle d' long terme
c'est presque une grille de lecture ou
un ou une une mauvaise compréhension de
ce qui'est devenu le Hamas du PO est-ce
qu'on l'a sous-estimé tiens je pourrais
poser cette question comme ça écoutez en
complément de ce qui VI de ce qui vient
d'être dit par votre correspondant en
Israël ouais en fait le le l'échec
premier mais pas le seul et celui des
services de renseignement c'est quand
même assez étonnant que de voir des
militants du Hamas en train de se
préparer avec des ULM s'entraîner avec
des motau et personne ne fait attention
à ça il y a quand même un une une faille
du renseignement du fininebê du Shabak
et et du service militaire du
renseignement
militaire tout monde est d'accord mais
mais posose la question sur la sous
est-ce que est-ce que c'est parce qu'on
les regardait plus d'une certaine façon
oui mais oui mais pourquoi il ne
regardait plus il faut il faut il il
faut regarder une chose c'est que le
service de renseignement fonctionne
toujours il ne fonctionne pas dans un
vide il fonctionne toujours dans un dans
une coupole dans laquelle se trouve en
fait tout le système politico euh
politicomitaire et et c'est comme pour
la guerre du Kipour la guerre du Kipour
en fait ils avaient tous les
renseignements nécessaires jusqu'à
vraiment la dernière minute mais ils y
croyent pas pas cro par que l'idée était
que l'armée égyptienne serait écrasée
par l'aviation israélienne et par les Ch
israélien et que donc il nerait pas
attaquer voilà et donc ils ont dit même
s'ils attaquent ils seront rejetés très
rapidement ici aussi je pense qu'il y a
eu un un une faille du du de
compréhension de de la conception
stratégique qui a été en fait élaboré
par il faut le dire au plus haut niveau
notamment par netan donc l'idée
principale était de dire éoutez je
rejoins un peu donc ce que yerusal
disait en fait un ramasse fort c'est bon
pour nous pourquoi parce que la société
israélienne est palestinienne est
divisée et donc on pourra dire qu'on n'a
pas avec qui négocier c'était une espèce
de garantie contre une pression
internationale qui souhaiterait
notamment les Américains qui
souhaiteraiit de reprendre que israélien
palestinien reprennent les négociations
et ça il y avait donc une troisième
erreur c'est de considérer que il
fallait aider le Hamas aussi
financièrement pour qu'il puisse en fait
se consacrer à la reconstruction de pays
et donc on a laissé passer de l'argent
notamment du Qatar du Qatar pas
notamment c'est de l'argent du Qatar et
laissé entrer des euh ouvriers euh
Palestiniens Gazaoui en Israël il y a eu
ces dernières années il y a eu 20000
permis d'entrée dans euh en Israël et
c'était l'idée que il y a quelques jours
en fait un des plus proches conseiller
de netan sah negbi disait en fait euh le
le Hamas n'est pas prêt et n'a aucune
n'est pas prêt à reprendre les
hostilités il y avait donc ce climat les
service de sécurité en fonctionner dans
cette dans ce climat là j'entends vos
explications aux uns et aux autres qui
sont passionnantes je j'apporte en
quelque sorte ma pierre à la
compréhension avec B un témoignage d'un
habitant de de zderot donc ville située
à environ 1 km de la bande de Gaza alors
il il dit tout ça et il parle aussi du
mur ou de la clôture qui a été
défaillante on l'écoute
tous les systèmes ont été défaillants
ici tout ce qui concerne le
renseignement le renseignement militaire
le renseignement civil tout ce qui
concerne les capteurs et la clôture tout
a été défaillant il devrait y avoir une
commission d'enquête sérieuse ici les
gens devrait être jugé pour chaque
erreur qu'ils ont
commise Jér cette barrière elle a coûté
je crois un milliard de dollars été
réputé
infranchissable aussi c'est une erreur
de conception comment vous
l'analysez menace était attendue par le
sous-sol et l'essentiel de l'effort
c'est un mur de 60 m de profondeur là
encore une fois la sidération vient du
fait que cette attaque asymétrique a
emprunté des vois et moyens inédites
presque indétectable en ce que elle
mobilise en fait des moyens militaires
qui n'en sont pas et donc peuvent
potentiellement passer sous le scope oui
mais les paramoteurs c'est quandme même
extrêmement-ce que vous appelez parur
des par à mur ok dit Mathieu est juste
on a tous vu les images d'un bu
question c'est vrai mais ça renvoie pas
ça renvoie pas tant à la question de la
réponse qui n'a pas été qui n'aurait pas
été suffisamment rapide parce que au
moment où s'est déclenché finalement
l'attaque et au moment où la sidération
a eu lieu la réponse de tsal a été
presque aussi bonne que possible ça
renvoie à la question de la prédiction
cette question de la prédiction elle se
pose selon moi selon trois axes le
premier déjà c'est est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment eu
défaillan on lit ici et là que le
ministre égyptien du renseignement
aurait averti Benjamin netanahou
lui-même sur la
possibilité d'un acte terroriste de
grande ampleur et en lui disant qu'il y
avait des agissements tout à fait
inusuels voilà il se peut donc qu'un
moment il y ait eu et ce serait pas la
première fois hein quand même dans
l'histoire des relations internationales
pas que que ça agissant d'Israël qui a
eu un yatus entre les services de
renseignement d'un côté et le politique
de l'autre sachant qu'on est dans un
climat institutionnel d'une d'une
extrême volatilité en Israël donc donc
vous dit c'est peut-être pas le les
services de renseignement qui est mais
le politique ça rejoint un peu l'analyse
queon pou
faire du coup évacue j'allais dire une
part de la défaillance en terme de
prédiction et après tout s'en déduit
parce que la réaction forcément est
dimensionnée structurée par la
prédiction il se peut aussi
effectivement qu'il ait eu dans cette
erreur j'allais dire de de prédiction un
mauvais calcul de la part de la part du
mossade en particulier et qu'ils aient
estimé que les buts de guerre du Hamas
ne seraient pas servi par une telle
action on voit que là ils se sont
trompés si c'était l'idée si c'était
d'éloigner la normalisation des
relations entre l'Arabie Saoudite et
Israël on sent que aux premières heures
des réactions des uns et des autres
qu'il se seraiit trompé et puis enfin
encore une fois et je reviens sur la
question que vous posiez sur le
parallèle avec l' hy misvre fa que en
matière de rignement vous devez faire
des choix vous pouvez pas tout éclairer
à 360 de dans toutes les dimension
économique
militaire stratégique cyber et cetera
vous êtes obligé de faire des choix et
donc à partir du moment où vous faites
des choix et le premier choix c'était
d'envisager comme scénario le plus
probable l'attaque multifront et c'est
l'attaque aussi qui serait la plus
délétaire contre contre Israël parce que
c'est celle qui pourrait remettre en
question l'existence même d'Israël ce
que met pas en question un attentat
terroriste aussi condamnable et aussi
dramatique c'est aussi le fait inédit
qu'il soit voilà et donc précisément si
vous n'éclairez pas tout si vous faites
des choix vous pouvez contenu des moyens
qui ont été mis en uvre ne pas le
détecter sur le renseignement à Gaza moi
j'ai une question de béoien mais il y a
eu 5000 roquettes tiré le premier jour
il y en a eu encore beaucoup depuis ça
se stock ça se construit c'est quand
même une zone sous embargo ça fait des
années que l'on sait que le Hamas
possède des dizaines de milliers de de
roquet ça fait des années que l'on sait
que la montée capacitaire je parle sous
votre contrôle la montée capacitaire du
Hamas se fait grâce à l'Iran s'agissant
des transferts de compétences s'agissant
des transferts de technologie ça fait
des années qu'on sait que le hzbollah
Libanais entraîne le Hamas et si l'on
n'a pas encore de fait avérés indiquant
que l'Iran spécifiquement et le hzbollah
spécifiquement sont à l'origine de la
planification et de la conduite de cette
de C attentat terroriste là bien qu'il y
ait déjà quelques quelques faisceaux
d'indice on est sûr que sur cette montée
en puissance progressive c'est eux et
c'est connu depuis Martin Go votre avis
les 30 millions de dollars que les 30
millions de dollars du Qatar que
Benjamin netanah a laissé depuis des
années
transféré transiter par le territoire
israélien pour rentrer dans Gaza et pour
justement selon cette éthique qui était
évoqué cette cette politique cette
illusion queil y avait une sorte de nor
noralité du ramass c'est ça qui a servi
aussi à fabriquer les armes par ailleurs
et à produire à continuer à creuser les
tunnels et pour creuser les tunnels il y
a aussi ce dont on ne parle jamais c'est
l'ouverture le le l'ouverture vers le
vers vers l'Égypte et l'Égypte a bel et
bien une Guera dans dans son dans son
désert avec daesh il il y avait il y
avait une quantité
d'infiltration depuis par par par Rafa
par l'ouverture égyptienne donc si vous
voulez il n'y a pas il y a pas un seul
élément mais le le ramas s'est senti
s'est senti fortifié depuis des années
aidé financièrement et politiquement
porté aux zénites depuis depuis quelques
mois notamment il y a il y a eu enfin
c'est très clair qu'il y a quelques
semaines à à à Berouth se sont
rencontrés euh les les les chefs le 2
octobre exact
les chefs des mouvements terroristes et
qu'il y a eu une sorte de de chè en
blanc de de donné à au déclenchement de
l'opération ça c'est ce qui ça c'est ce
qui commence à sortir donc voilà non non
mais elle hésite concl votre non mais il
y a il y a donc cette espèce de gouffre
qui est de de que le renseignement que
le renseignement est averti je le répète
oui et oui il y a eu des avertissements
à iaou mais il y a eu aussi une sorte de
quand même de technicité du ramas parce
que le lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ils ont
immédiatement désactivé les systèmes
d'alertes parce que il y avait tout de
même des il y avait tout de même des
systèmes d'alerte qui devaient et la la
réactivité la réactivité de tsal elle
elle a été nulle et non avenu C c'était
fait alors je redonne la parole à
Raphael jérusalemi parce que je vous ai
interrompu au cours de de de votre
première intervention vous disiez donc
une explication de long terme et on
vient de la la nourrir de de des
analyses de nos autres invités et vous
aviez une autre explication je veux bien
l'entendre
oui je crois que vos invités ont
d'ailleurs euh intervenants ont donné
euh cette explication plus ou moins euh
à laquelle j'ajoute quand même que même
s'il y a une défaance euh sur le plan du
renseignement he je vais vous donner un
exemple euh on parle de de ces fameux
ULM on parle de de de ces missiles
euh il y a eu une défaillance par
exemple par rapport au déton ateur pour
les exposifs que détient le Hamas les
détonateurs qui sont au main du Hamas
ont été commandés par sur le réseau
Alibaba mais ils ont été commandés en
pièces détachées et donc arrivant par
Alibaba de Chine arrivaient des pièces
détachées qui n'avaient rien à voir les
unes avec les autres séparément mais un
employé des postes qui avait fait sa
réserve dans le génie militaire a
compris que ce fil là avec ce bouton là
ça ça faisait un détonateur et donc
c'est comme ça qu'on est tombé là-dessus
mais sinon ça passait très très bien
sous le nez et la barbe des services de
renseignement une autre tactique il faut
pas oublier que cette opération est
préparée par le ramas depuis 1 an déjà
donc avant l'arrivée au pouvoir du
nouveau gouvernement avant même le chaos
politique dont nous parlons beaucoup
nous nous référons à ce chaos politique
peut-être pour le timing mais cela fait
1 an que le ramas prépare euh cette
opération et donc il faut se demander
quel en est l'objectif que compte euh
euh parce que normalement si le
gouvernement israélien fait son travail
et si l'armée se reprend le le ramas
vient de signer son arrêt de mort que
voulait-il obtenir par une cette
opération donc pendant 1 an en ayant
bien étudié son ennemi en étudiant la
mentalité et les mouvements de l'ennemi
il a préparé cette opération et il a
endormi euh l'ennemi par exemple il nous
a fait croire et vraiment même moi que
euh le le le jouer la carte
socio-économique qui est humanitaire à
l'égard de Gaza de donner des permis de
travail au Gazaoui pour venir en Israël
de laisser de plus en plus de
marchandises rentrer dans la bande de
Gaza pour améliorer les conditions de
vie avait calmé le ramas et le gramas
s'est bien abstenu de mener des
opérations terroristes alors que la
jeudé à Samarie il y avait plein
d'attentats le le Gaza était
relativement calme et on commençait donc
déjà à endormir l'ennemi ensuite au lieu
de arrêter et torturer les indicateurs
Gazaoui qui travaillent pour Israël le
khamas quand il en a repéré n'a rien
fait et leur a fourni tout simplement de
fausses informations qui ont été
évidemment communiqué à leurs agents
activateur israélien et cetera et cetera
donc il y ici com comment ça pardon n
interrompe ça ce sont des informations
qui sont sorties depuis quoi depuis 48
he sur cette stratégie du Hamas qui date
d' a un an à comprendre oui alors alors
on on cherche à comprendre parce que
aujourd'hui on a comme je l'ai dit on
avait les yeux bandés il y a eu un
aveuglement certain et donc aujourd'hui
et on est loin de savoir et je vous
garanti que les commissions d'enquête
qui auront lieu après cette guerre
mettront des mois et des années à nous
donner des résultats mais ce que je
voudrais signaler c'est quand même
important c'est que cette défaillance du
rignement elle peut avoir lieu on peut
pas à chaque fois deviner tout et
partout et et cetera là là où il y a eu
la grande grande grande défaillance
c'est sur le plan opérationnel sur le
terrain c'est-à-dire une fois qu'il y a
eu cette surprise euh ce scénario
catastrophe qui commence il y a eu
maintenant un délai vraiment
inacceptable de réaction des trouples
sur le terrain et ça à mon avis ça
mérite beaucoup plus notre attention que
une FA du renseignement alors il y a une
question que je voudrais aborder
maintenant c'est la question des otages
parce qu'elle est évidemment sans
centrale dans dans l'analyse de de cette
attaque terroriste du du Hamas
l'objectif c'était de tuer et aussi de
prendre des otages des militaires et des
civils Sami Cohen est-ce qu'on sait
parce que moi dans les titres j'ai dit
entre 100 et 150 personnes pourquoi il y
a il y a un tel flou aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on sait précisément combien d'otages
sont détenus par le Hamas non on le sait
pas je crois que le Hamas va peu
communiquer sur cette question on a
beaucoup dit euh
tout récemment qu'Israël va essayer de
négocier le rapatriment de de ces otages
en échange de libération de de
terroristes palestiniens qui sont dans
les jaoles israéliennes je n'y crois pas
un seul instant le Hamas n'a pas intérêt
à négocier parce que dans même même même
s'il réussit à libérer tous les
prisonniers palestiniens dans les
prisons israëliennes il n'a aucun
intérêt à partir du moment où il libère
les otages il devient totalement
vulnérable aux frappes israéliennes il
va pas le faire il va garder cette carte
comme une protection comme un comme un
bouclier de protection pendant un
certain temps jusqu'à ce que les choses
se calment donc euh voilà un peu le
sentiment que j'ai concernant les aut
mais si vous voulez est-ce que je peux
ver un point sur ce qu'on a discuté qui
est un point très important un tout
petit peu important pour rebondir sur ce
que Martine disait à propos des
euh du fait que au fond pourquoi est-ce
que la bande de la le pourtour de la
bande de Gaza était aussi dégarni c'est
incroyable j'ai des amis qui qui ont
attendu des heures et des heures avant
de pouvoir joindre le standard de
l'armée qui ne répondait pas mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
effectivement c'est une question
politique majeure c'est pas une question
de de militaire c'est l'investissement
massif des forces israéliennes en 6
jordordanie pourquoi h parce que euh les
colons sont c'est l'électorat
majeur des proches alliés de netaniaah
et donc nan n voilà il a il a autorisé
de
sursécuriser des colonies qui sont déjà
sécurisés attendez
attendeze il faut la protection par avec
des arguments politiques juste un point
pour terminer en
échange les les les communautés qui
vivent au sud au sud d'Israël ce n'est
pas le le à part ici ou là quelques
quelques localités ce n'est pas
l'électorat de de l'extrême droite ce n
pas l'ctg électorat je connais beaucoup
de localités où le likout est arrivé en
3e 4e position et donc c'est colon
d'abord ok bande de Gaza je peux vous
dire ce que vous venez de nous dire ça
fait réagir à faire jérusalemi vous
demandez la parole je vous la donne tout
de suite rapidement je vis qu'on parle
des otages après rapidement Israël est
divisé en trois commandements
commandement Nord commandement centre
commandement Sud euh ça rien à voir les
décisions stratégiques de l'armée n'ont
rien à voir avec soutenir ou pas les
implantations et le gouvernement de
Benjamin natanahou euh c'est c'est pas
du tout ça et une des raisons
principales pour laquelle il n'y avait
pas suffisamment de troupes sur le
terrain c'est que nous étions dans la
fête et le shabbat de souscôte où des
grands de beaucoup de permissions ont
été accordé aux soldats et au soldat et
ça a déjà réduit de plus de 30 % les
effectifs euh il n'y a pas là
il y a une décision politique en général
un aveuglement c'est vrai de Benjamin
naniaahou sur ce que ce qui est le Hamas
il s'est trompé mais sur le plan
opérationnel il y avait un manque
d'effectif et donc qui était évidemment
la résultante de de de la défaillance du
renseignement et il y avait pas assez de
troupes sur le terrain et ça a pris du
temps pour les faire revenir pardon de
vous interrompre mais je voilà de points
de vue on va pas continuer sur ce
thèmeel parce que je voudrais vraiment
Jérôme clè qu'on parle des otages
qu'est-ce que ça change là pour la
repost israélienne pour ce qui peut se
passer déjà maintenant ou ce qui va se
passer dans les prochains jours tout ça
change tout en fait et ça explique aussi
le délai de réponse que notre
interlocuteur en duplexe trouvait un peu
long quand je disais que tsal avait
réagi aussi bien que possible comp tenu
du contexte le contexte a inclu
évidemment les deux fêtes parce qu'il y
en avait pas une mais les deux fêtes
religieuses les deux fêtes religieuses
juives qui crée effectivement un
contexte favorable pour une attaque hein
et ça s'est produit comme ça déjà il y a
50 ans voilà euh et puis
euh lorsqu'il y a des otages en jeu de
fait vous vous posez la question de des
marges de manœuvres qui sont les vôtres
et puis c'est pas un otage c'est plus de
100 otages avec des civils des
militaires des personnes âgées des
enfants des autorités militaires donc
vos marges de manœuvre sont extrêmement
réduites c'est déjà énorme que la
dimension la composante aérienne de tsal
soit intervenue si rapidement par plus
de 21 frappes sur des C nal pour sa la
puissance de frapp en TER dequ voilà
déjà là cétait un Paris me semble-til
parce que il aurait pu avoir une
réaction du Hamas sur ce sujet là quand
vous avez plus d'une centaine d'otage
pardon d'entrer dans ces détails mais
vous pouvez égrainer l'exécution des
otages aussi voilà c'est une possibilité
donc la vie est en jeu sur la dimension
terrestre alors même que sur les
plateaux les uns et les autres disait
relayant effectivement les déclarations
du Premier ministre netanah que il y
aurait une attaque fulgurante et massive
de la composante terrestre de Tsahal sur
la bande de Gaza en fait il n'en est
rien aujourd'hui on a un état de siège
pour l'instant donc le fait d'y aller
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais sur des
œufs et ce qui peut différer la réaction
est entièrement indexé sur le fait qu'il
y a des autage Mathieu vouliz intervenir
est-ce que le nombre d'otage d'une
certaine façon ne change pas
complètement la donne quand on se
souvient entre guillimets du prix payé
par Israël pour libérer Guilad Chadid
c'était 1000 prisonniers je crois pour
un pour un soldat là le fait qu'il y en
a 100 boulement c'est un bouleversement
total et c'est pour cela que je suis un
peu en retrait de toutes les
comparaisons ça n'est comparable à rien
c'est une c'est une c'est une tragédie
majeure parce que le ce piège qui s'est
refermé hein que comme comme on le
disait tous sur Israël ouvre un un abîme
à l'intérieur de la société israélienne
chaque chaque chaque israélien chaque
israélienne traverse depuis depuis 48 he
des jours et des nuits où euh il il a
une sorte de de de de seconde vie
fantomatique et cauchemardesque c'est
c'est c'est ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on me
dit c'est ce que c'est ce que les les
les les les amis les relations que j'ai
noué depuis tant d'années et tant
d'années sur dans ce pays me disent nous
nous songeons à chaque instant à ce que
vivent ces hommes ces femmes ces enfants
et c'est c'est quelque chose c'est un
abîme qui qui renvoie qui renvoie pas
seulement à à l'histoire d'Israël depuis
sa fondation en 1948 parce que rien de
rien de tel ne s'est jamais produit le
le 73 ça n'a rien à voir c'est clair
c'était des
armé et en même temps la sauve et à la
très longue histoire juive parce que ce
que nous avons vu dans cette rêve partie
ces images absolument atroc donc là
c'est une je rappelle même si je pense
que no téléspectateurs voilà savent ce
qui s'est passé une rêve partie qui est
organisé d'ailleurs à une dizaine de
kilomètres de de la bande de Gaza et et
c'est vrai qu'une par une grande partie
des otages et de morts d'ailleurs vient
vient de là absolument mais c'était des
jeunes gens et des jeunes filles qui
étaient pour la paix c'était et c'est ça
illustre tellement bien cette cette
société israélienne qui qui qui rêve de
la normalité qui s'était mis presque sur
la frontière et qui cette illusion oui
c'est c'est l'illusion d'un pays
complètement protégé c'est ça qui est
c'est ce que ça dit aussi organiser une
fête comme celle-là à 10 km de la
frontière c'est l'illusion et c'est
aussi ensuite en en revers le en miroir
ténébreux c'est la sauvagerie la
sauvagerie que nous avons vu se déployer
à travers les vidéos devant nous et qui
renvoie quelque chose d'effrayant qui
renvoie au pogrom les gens
racontaient quelques survivants
racontaient comment il s'étaaiit cachés
dans les bosquets comment on a vu ces
photos floutées ces vidéos floutées
pardon moi j'ai vu l'intégralité des des
des des jeunes filles enlevé arrivant à
Gaza ensanglanté sur lesquels se
jetaient des meutes d'hommes au cri de
allahakbar comment peut-on comment
peut-on supporter ces images comment un
peuple peut le supporter c'est ça la
faille géante ouverte dans l'âme dans
l'âme israélienne et qui et qui
ressuscite qui réveille pardon qui
réveille qui
réactive le fantôme le fantôme de
l'extermination alors je je reviens sur
la question de la de la
riposte de l'armée israélienne et du
pouvoir israélien je vous propose
d'entendre le ministre de la Défense sur
Galand qui annonce vous l'avez évoqué le
siège complet de la bande de
Gaza nous imposons un siège complet à
Gaza pas d'électricité pas de nourriture
pas d'eau pas de gaz tout est fermé nous
sommes confrontés à des sauvages et
devons agir en
conséquence et j'accueille Steve
Jourdain sur ce plateau bonsoir Steve
pour nous dire tout simplement la bande
de Gaza de quoi on parle superficie 360
km² largeur entre 6 et 12 km c'est un
territoire qui est situé entre la mer
Méditerranée le désert du Sinaï et le
territoire israélien on le voit à l'est
et au nord la Gaza dont on parle
aujourd'hui Thomas fixe ses traits en
1948 au moment de la première guerre
israélo-arabe qui va donner naissance à
l'État d'Israël à la suite du conflit ce
qu'on va appeler la bande de Gaza passe
alors sous contrôle égyptien en 1948 on
compte 260000 habitants aujourd'hui on
en compte environ 2 millions les 2 tiers
des Gazaouis aujourd'hui sont des
descendants des réfugiés palestiniens
qui ont fui les combats pendant la
guerre de 48 Gaza qui passera ensuite
sous contrôle israélien oui alors c'est
bien savoir qu'entre 48 et 67 il n'y a
aucun israélien à Gaza en 1967
effectivement éclate la guerre des 6
jours une coalition de pays arabes mené
par l'Égypte menace de détruire Israël
en 6 jours l'État hébreu renverse sa
situation et s'empare de nouveaux
territoires dont la bande de Gaza des
colonies israéliennes ils sont
progressivement implanté alors pas
beaucoup pas beaucoup Thomas rien à voir
avec ce dont on parle aujourd'hui
notamment en 6 Jordanie au plus fort de
cette colonisation il n'y aura jamais
plus de 8000 israéliens à Gaza fait
important Thomas dans les années 70 et
dans les années 80 Gaza est une ville
dite ouverte une partie de la population
gazaou travaille en Israël et des
Israéliens viennent à Gaza pour faire
des courses pour faire leur marché comme
et bien ce qu'on peut voilà comme
n'importe quel citoyen autre date de
bascule décembre 1986 la première
Intifada qui éclate précisément à Gaza
c'est là et bien la suite d'un accident
entre un camion israélien et une voiture
palestinienne que le soulèvement
palestinien débute pourquoi à Gaza et
bien parce que c'est historiquement le
lieu de prédilection de la mobilisation
politique palestinienne le Fatar de
Yasser Arafat il y a toujours été très
implanté en 87 un nouveau acteur un
nouvel acteur va émerger le Hamas dont
on parle aujourd'hui le Hamas un groupe
islamiste bras armé des Frères musulmans
égyptiens dans l'idéologie du Hamas les
chrétiens les juifs sont des infidèles
Israël est voé à l'extinction l'objectif
de l'organisation est de chasser tous
les Juifs de ce qu'ils appellent la
Palestine qui est vu comme un territoire
sain un territoire sacré à défendre le
Hamas qui va multiplier des attentats
attentat sanglan qui va pousser Israël à
se coupé de Gaza oui 1993 les accords
d'Oslo ils sont signés entre Israël et
l'Autorité palestinienne c'est le début
de ce qu'on appelle le processus de paix
mais le Hamas n'en veut pas il organise
depuis Gaza une vague d'attentat
islamiste ce qui pousse Israël à se
barricader les point de passage depuis
la bande de Gaza se referme
progressivement et se ferme de manière
plus nette encore dans les dans la
décennie qui suivent en août 2005 Ariel
Charon Premier ministre de droite décide
de couper le cordon et leur donne
l'évacuation de la bande de Gaza et le
mouvement islamiste va totalement
prendre le pouvoir dans les mois qui
viennent oui après l'évacuation il n a
donc plus aucun israélien dans la bande
de Gaza en 2006 des élections
législatives sont organisé dans les
territoires palestiniens le triomphe est
total pour le Hamas qui obtient la
majorité absolue mais une guerre civile
sanglante va éclater entre les factions
palestiniennes les islamistes s'emparent
de la zone par la force en réaction en
2007 Israël et l'Égypte ordonne le
boocus de la bande de Gaza un blocus
encore en vigueur au moment où on se
parte mal mais on l'aura compris un
blocus qui aura quand même permis et
bien de laisser passer des milliers
d'armes des milliers de missiles des
milliers de roquettes dont se sont
servis les terroristes merci beaucoup
Steve pour toutes ces explications je
reviens au au au siège complet dont on
parlait Jérôme clche pas pas d'eau pas
d'entrée de nourriture l'électri cité le
gaz et cetera est-ce que on peut
imaginer pardon ma question est
peut-être naïve mais que le Hamas a
anticipé ça c'estd qu'on j'allais dire
combien de temps peuvent-ils tenir un
siège quoi ça je serais bien incapable
de vous répondre à C à ces deux
questions là puisque votre question est
double une chose est certaintaine c'est
que ça semble être la seule voie pour
Tsahal et
pour pour la composante terrestre d'agir
de façon à faire pression sans doute sur
la population pour que la population se
désolidarise c'est sans doute l'effet
escompté du Hamas l'idée étant à terme
de pousser le Hamas sans doute à
négocier pour un échange pour un échange
de d'otage d'un côté de prisonnier de
l'autre c'est pas tout à fait les les
mêmes mots voilà d'un côté la barbarie
de l'autre quand même un modèle de
civilisation voilà donc il faut quand
même remettre les choses voilà à leur
place donc négociation oui mais
asymétrique euh après cette négociation
vous disiez le Hamas n'y aurait pas
intérêt il faut bien avoir conscience
que et on le disait déjà et c'est vrai
d'un point de vue plus général le Hamas
n'agit pas seul le Hamas est
l'instrument d'une guerre par
procuration plus largement quand on dit
que ça n'a pas été prédit ça n'a pas été
prédit il faut être précis sur le lieu
l'heure et les modalités mais
intellectuellement ça a été prédit vous
regardez de belles analyses fait sur
des radios de de comment de du service
public français où il y a 3 semaines un
peu plus de 3 semaines je crois euh on
parlait euh à peu près en ces termes de
la situation et si on avait rapproché
l'analyse de des événements qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui on aurait presque eu
l'impression qu'on parlait de la même
chose donc intellectuellement ça était
prévu le problème c'est que tactiquement
ça ne l'a pas été ou ça l'a été mais ça
n'a pas été entendu ce qui est un autre
problème tout ça pour dire quoi que la
situation géopolitique générale avec
l'Iran à la manœuvre et le Hezbollah est
quelque chose qu'il faut prendre en
compte et le Hamas ne décidera pas seul
de ce qui fait de ses otages bien sûr on
en reparlera longuement dans dans la
deuxème partie d'émission Matthieu
est-ce qu'on a une idée de la du soutien
de la population au Hamas on sait qu'il
y a pas eu d'élections depuis 17 ans on
dit que les premières victimes du Hamas
ce sont les Palestiniens de Gaza est-ce
que est-ce que voilà comment comment rag
la population peutêtre Samus non
franchement on a pas beaucoup
d'information
on sait que le le le gaz lamda ce qui
souhaitent c'est c'est vivre honnêtement
correctement euh faire grandantir s
enfants éventuellement envoyer s enfants
à l'étranger tout ça n'est pas possible
et et et le problème c'est que la bande
de Gaza est sous un régime dictatorial
et et et par conséquent la marge de
marge de manœuvre des populations qui
sont modérées est très limité il y a pas
de révolte possible parce qu'elle sera
noyée dans le sang immédiatement l'ont
été déjà il y a eu des il y a eu des
manifestations il mais il y a toutes ces
ces derniers mois il y a eu des
tentatives de manifestation et il y a eu
euh il y a eu à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs entre guillemets au moment
des des printemps de ces fameux
printemps arabes qui ont tourné en hiver
de toute façon l'hiver islamiste était
déjà déclaré à Gaza il y a eu des des
des manifestations à Gaza qui ont été
sauvagement réprimé aussi des femmes qui
sont sorties qui refusent absolument le
le statut qu' leur ait fait c'est-à-dire
que euh le le nous avons nous avons en
face de nous une tyrannie et là je
rejoins toutes les analyses et de
Raphaël jérusalemi et de de nos amis sur
sur l'ADN du ramas on s'est trompé sur
l'ADN du ramas d'ailleurs ce que disait
exactement ce que vient ce que vient de
de lâcher un un ancien conseiller à la
sécurité nationale qui s'appelle Yaakov
Dr il dit nous avons commis une erreur
monumentale en croyant qu'une
organisation terroriste pouvait modifier
modifier son ADN c'est tout depuis sa
création il a dit on l' on l'a redit il
veut un état islamique sur
l'intégralité de de du territoire
israélien et deou c'est tout nous avons
nous avons face nous sommes face à à à
une sauvagerie et un état intégriste je
vous propose d'entendre l'une des
réactions pr ministre isralien benam n
déclare son pays en guerre évidemment il
il décrit l'ennemi c'est le
Hamas tous les endroits où le Hamas
s'entraîne tous les endroits où le Hamas
se cache partout d'où il opère nous
allons en faire des
ruines je dis aux habitants de Gaza
sortez de là
maintenant car nous allons agir partout
avec toute notre
force Raphaël Jérusalem je reviens vers
vous qu'est-ce qui peut se passer là
maintenant dans les prochaines heures
dans les prochains
jours alors tout d'abord cette décision
du gouvernement et annoncé par le
ministre de la
défense d'un blocus total d'affamer en
fait Gaza c'est d'abord ce que nous ne
voulions pas c'est-à-dire nous voulions
dissocier le peuple palestinien des
terroristes mais par des actions
humanitaires justement le contraire et
là nous sommes obligés pour faire plier
le ramas car nous n'avons aucune autre
solution on peut bombarder Gaza City
autant qu'on veut on narrivera jamais à
atteindre les otages qui sont maintenant
dispersés dans plusieurs cachettes on
estime entre 20 et 30 endroits
différents dans Gaza dans la bande de
Gaza où les groupes de de captifs ont
été donc dispersé et il y a aucune façon
donc par la force euh militaire en tous
les cas euh de faire plier le framas qui
ne veut pas négocier qui va d'ailleurs
moi je vais vous dire tout de suite par
par où ça va commencer les négociation
le prix va être exorbitant dès le départ
juste pour avoir la liste des noms des
gens qui sont détenus là-bas car nous ne
savons pas combien sont détenus que et
et s'ils sont vivants donc juste pour
obtenir cette information ils vont déjà
monayer ça maintenant la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'effectivement il y a une
détermination telle que malgré ce que
cela ne peut nous coûter par exemple en
soutien de l' opinion publique
internationale en ce moment nous
jouissons de la compassion et de la
sympathie du monde mais si nous avons un
un blocus sur Gaza et on voit des des
des enfants Gazaoui avoir faim je pense
que ce soutien va pas durer longtemps et
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle et aussi
une mauvaise nouvelle nous n'avons pas
le choix nous devons mettre à genou le
ramas euh et là je pense que cette
stratégie va pas être nécessairement
payante par parce que le Hamas se fiche
bien de voir mourir les enfants
palestiniens de faim eux ils auront dans
leur bonkerer tout ce qu'il y a de bon
de chez Fauchon ou ailleurs à manger je
peux vous garantir que il y a plein
plein à manger dans les bnkers du Hamas
et qui peuvent soutenir ce siège et il
se fiche complètement de du sort des des
autres d'autant plus que plus le peuple
palestinien souffrira plus les
Israéliens on l'air d'être d'être les
méchants donc on est véritablement dans
un cercle vicieux ce qui a réussi à
accir le ramasse en tous les cas c'est
de nous coincer quoi que nous
fassions ça va être perçu comme comme
violent ou disproportionné comme on a
l'habitude de le dire mais cette fois-ci
je pense nous n'avons pas le choix ce
qui est arrivé à nos citoyens on ça ne
peut pas arriver une deuxième fois ça ne
peut plus jamais arriver il faut aller
jusqu'au B merci beaucoup merci Raphaël
jérusalemi le piège finalement dans
lequel le Hamas le piège tendu par le
Hamas dans lequel l'État Israël ne
pouvait que tomber merci à tous d'avoir
participé à cette première partie je
vais citer vos livres Jérôme clèche la
prospective stratégique aux éditions
Herman Martine gozlandand Israël 70 ans
7p clés pour comprendre cette aux
édition de l'archipel et Sami Cohen sal
à l'épreuve du terrorisme au seuil merci
encore d'avoir participé à à ce premier
débart